who does
oh for sure too many dating apps that's
a No-No if you have like two it's I but
down you're like going on all these
dating apps
here we go
nobody has this accent those fake
titties and doesn't have a popping
Instagram
find out oh you'll find out all right
what do you think our follower account
is
um 225 I'm gonna say 75k
I don't even know who that girl is I
don't know either one million is that
her that's her that's one million
million that was closest there's
something about those titties and not an
accent you have to be an influencer
there's no way you're not yeah
um all right so I'm on the home phone he
likes McDonald's Burger King Wendy's
stock wise that's disgusting I'm sorry
it's one thing to eat out of those
places when you got the [ __ ]
app that's [ __ ] nasty am I crazy
group them together hold on you're just
wait it's not so much a group they know
what they did they know what they did we
organize their dysfunction yeah which is
fine possible mad bro what are those abs
why do people even download those apps
for do you get coupons
no you just download them that's random
bro and also McDonald's in America is
disgusting it literally tastes like dog
poop I haven't had it that many times I
think once or twice so Candace
McDonald's decent you know as a kid I
used to eat I don't go out of McDonald's
in the states bro I haven't been to
McDonald's in general in like five years
yeah when I used to eat it I wouldn't
remember when America and I had it and
I'm like [ __ ] is this the same
franchise then I went to Portugal and
had it then I said [ __ ] is this the
same franchise They do change the phase
depending on where they are oh yes
because the regulator is different yo
McDonald's is not the same in America in
Canada or in Europe and I'm sure people
told me even Asia people say about area
it's like restaurant everywhere
everywhere like when I went to the
states and I went to Virginia yeah like
20 years ago I went to Virginia and
that's the last time I tasted some some
American McDonald's I usually I would
use back then order a quarter pounder
yeah I ordered it there it was it was
greasy between two months
it's a lot isn't it I was like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah and then you didn't
you chuckle when they said do you want
this bottle and they pull out a big one
yeah I was like what am I eating for
five minutes I was thirsty not dirty I
don't want to take a bath in a thing
what the [ __ ] yo
you go to the bathroom bruh
oh okay when I'm feeling oh okay yeah
okay
honestly those are good dating apps I
can't complain about those
Bumble and Tinder are good dating apps
they're dating apps
I like that he he labeled it when I'm
feeling lonely at least he's honest
about it because a lot of people do
views on how many women I know [ __ ]
get on Tinder start swiping match with
people just delete the app like two days
later yeah so uh yeah and then do the
same thing next month when they get
broken up with yeah but when they watch
a movie and see love on the screen yeah
there you go definitely some of you felt
targeted I'm targeting you yeah that's
exactly you that's you the Hollywood
Tower Hotel so did you take that photo
yeah okay so he's a photographer okay
dude takes a regular picture the girl oh
he's a photographer
oh
he has a followers app so that means
like he's an influencer no I'm just
Petty
appreciate the honesty dude bro no no no
I'm just Petty I don't think she
recognizes that she comes across the
Airhead are you
on I'm buying oh yeah buy it okay that's
what's up oh okay you'll be selling
clothes okay so you're an entrepreneur
nah nah nah I'm a customer okay broke
I'm gonna wait she got turned off when
he said nah I'm buying yeah yeah she's
at that's not mine yeah oh this guy's
funny for sure because he has an app
called iFunny he's funny because he has
I funny
like whatever I have a face and a book
because I got Facebook what the [ __ ] is
this
did she look at his phone but try to
look at her reflection play that [ __ ]
back play that [ __ ] did she just ain't
no because she's trying to you trying to
she's trying to catch it bro bro I told
you bro it's a little thing bro I took
one look at her I'm like this [ __ ] got
Instagram for sure and he's on Prime
okay so he's a fast in technology he's
on Amazon yeah he seems really smart
because he plays chess
you know what the [ __ ] you was doing
with that one I don't know how to work
at Android so he's lucky oh he's Asian
for sure because he has like Asian like
fonts
um and he watches anime I see him like
do you know how many black people watch
anime oh yeah I guess you just didn't
expect anybody else to speak Japanese so
when she saw the letters and the anime
she just assumed the person oh my God
that guy is Asian for sure oh he's Asian
for sure I wish I was
maybe if I get isekai I'll come back as
a Japanese man
this is the most Vanity Vanity 100.
Android
I'm sorry we called it I'm sorry I
caused this something we call about this
girl where you could tell she's the type
of person
we iPhones only we called it bro we said
that I lived in California so I've been
around basic women like this before it's
insane how vain they are and unaware as
well but to be fair dudes are the reason
why they're that unaware because dudes
will send for them anyways oh my God
it's like it's hard
maybe it's because she's an airhead but
everything she says I'm just thinking
about her look so when she goes uh it's
hard I'm like yeah
I will be a Savage about it one of his
frequently used Emoji is like the purple
evil oh it's from a guy group chat oh
your mom and dad text you be careful
they're here alone I love my mom I love
my dad all right but let's see if you
[ __ ] boy let's see the wiener the purple
emoji no not not too much oh you ain't a
fuckboy damn okay let's go into the
purple emoji really on the hunt for this
purple emoji that's the Emoji the top
secret okay I'm gonna go into that
listen to those girls like [ __ ] Nails
on a chalkboard it's like sharp teeth on
my dick
yelling at chalkboard yeah Nails in my
ears
oh [ __ ] it seems like a boys group chat
yeah super super top secret stuff in
there
um Airbnb where are you going here
actually okay how are you staying here
for leaving tomorrow night okay I'll see
you tomorrow yeah
that's how these women reject you they
just yeah yeah
that smell Gala Christine oh that's my
mom Gail Christie wow you know you put
her as Mom that's how you know you're
close to your mom when you can call her
by her first name that's how you can get
we'll buy your mom too by calling him by
her first name I'm not doing that [ __ ]
no
hey what up [ __ ] don't call me that
who does
that's so stupid
I'll understand why
I I could never
my mom would look at me if I said and
she's like are you okay
huh yo
dude
my mom the first time wouldn't say
nothing because she was just like he
must be messing around uh
are you okay
what's wrong
what do you mean why are you safe
well I say what why you say I hear you
all say that
my mom just get my mom doesn't finish
her sentence so if you don't know to put
in the extra word you're confused why
you say it why you say what why you say
she thinks she says something too my mom
be killing me bro oh that's why you
don't care about me not having complete
sentences because your mom is the same
yeah yeah I have to put a few extra
words my mama everything is like a quiz
a trivia there you go what's the word
that finishes this sentence
figure it out [ __ ] it's not that she
says to you that sounds fun ah you come
what
you come home
are you sure
okay
that's some funny [ __ ] oh my God it's
four guys now oh my God wait what camera
roll so she's gonna see the pictures you
can pick the hottest one nightclubs
where are you going I don't know
actually oh okay it's just like bad live
performance oh yeah just like him going
out with his friends oh he's a family
man for sure you have like silly friends
that means that you're silly people that
make me laugh I love them oh you go
Vegas
you turn up
I like that I like to have fun too
oh wow you go to fashion shows too uh
yeah I'm a designer myself what a dog
you travel to go to Paris
yeah you get lit like you just turn up
I'm like yeah
oh my God it's so [ __ ] basic it's
frightening you get lit like oh my God
it's so lit oh my God it's so lit it's
like lit I could never take this [ __ ]
anyway like yeah
I had to choose one who do you think
she's going for the black dude
I agree
first one is Geo
I just feel like we're not compatible
with the pictures and next one is Lucas
yeah yeah it's all good I just feel like
I'm too grown for you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
that's not my bed oh my God she said
grown [ __ ] you got the intellect of a
toddler what the [ __ ] did you say oh my
days doubt I'm gonna go with the guy who
turns up a lot wait so I'm canceling
Connor sorry
[Music]
well she saw that money lifestyle she's
like [ __ ] uh I'm an Instagram girl
that's my stop
final question
no wow
if you aren't aware everybody who comes
to the set has to wear black and
let me just uh together
[Laughter]
that's enough of her Jubilee I know you
can do better
the people know they're kind of [ __ ]
up Jubilee by letting them see the
camera roll because then she could see
what they look like and I feel like she
chose based off Batman
what else would you choose from I mean
just the phones that's the whole point
of this anyways uh this was really
stupid she's really dumb I um
I don't have anything inside it's not
dumb she just wants to turn up yeah it's
lit
stop dragging this and let's let this
end oh my gosh you got a shirt just
really well